set big goals to keep you motivated I
got a great question from one of my
loyal youtube viewers love you guys I am
greater who wrote in to say do you
already have a video or can you make one
that explains how to say your goals so
big that you must work on it every
minute of the day I currently feel like
I'm too comfortable in my situation I'm
still doing what I love but there's
nothing that's pushing me to move faster
forward this is a great question and one
that you know you're kind of in a lucky
position to have but a lot of us as
entrepreneurs we set our goals too low
we set our goals too low and then when
you accomplish them instead of feeling
great which lasts for a couple seconds
you then get depressed because you have
nothing to do now because you set your
goal too low I remember when I sold my
first company you know I'm so proud and
building this thing I posed I was 19
when I started in it and I was making a
300 bucks a month and you know barely
able to survive and turning it around to
having a team and customers and
something I could be proud of
and when we're looking at selling a
company and getting acquired it was a
thrill that the hunt you know the thrill
of the chase and things are happening
the companies are interested in us and
and we're gonna get a deal how much is
gonna be worth let's sign the papers
here we go we're selling and so much
excitement enthusiasm and happiness and
then you sign it and then the next day
was terrible you know I achieved my goal
and I didn't know what to do with my
life I didn't know what to do next
it's a spoiled problem to have you know
I had I had some money obviously from
the sale not enough to retire on but I
didn't have to go work but you get your
happiness not from money is from doing
something important something that
you're contributing to and the next
little while in my life was really it
was hard I had to find what I love to do
I didn't know what I wanted to do I
remember I I carried a journal with me
just to keep track of activities that I
did in
day that I liked because I was I was
struggling to find something to keep
going because I lost you know my dream
happened my goal happened I didn't know
what to do next and I eventually found
my passion of helping entrepreneurs and
building this business to support people
who are trying to create their own
companies and and I created a big goal
of helping a billion entrepreneurs in
part after listen to advice from Ted
Turner and Ted is a multi billionaire
successful entrepreneur and his advice
is set goals that you will never achieve
in your lifetime so you always have
something to work for
and that came as a result of his dad who
had a goal to be a millionaire and get
his own yacht and he worked really hard
to accomplish that and he eventually did
his dad became a millionaire and got his
own yacht and from that day Ted Turner's
dad's life totally changed he became
depressed he lost his guts he says he
says himself he didn't know what he
wanted to do with his life and he became
depressed and he eventually killed
himself when Ted I think was around
twenty four years old and for Ted like
that's what happens when you accomplish
your goal so he always said major goals
for himself that he felt like he could
never accomplish so he never would have
that same fate as his dad but it is very
common you know you reach your goal and
you feel depressed or you're not
motivated you're lethargic you're you're
comfortable you're just doing what you
do day in day out and it gets boring
your productivity drops and you get the
pride that that you know that comes into
your personal life - you're not as happy
with your your spouse or your kids and
your friends and your lacking energy so
it's important to find one big goal for
me helping a billion entrepreneurs
that's not going to happen overnight
it's a lot of work and I would get wake
up and I'm not I'm not going
every day super-motivated yahoo we go
raw but it does motivate me to keep
going and more Jason make more videos
like this and create more content and do
more presentations and interviews and
gives me energy
knowing that I'm helping people so set
big goals it's okay to have little goals
these little milestones along the way
but set big goals too to help keep you
motivated to help realize you know what
you're doing something important and
anything that is really important should
be big your goal should be something
that you can get done quickly because
this is what you're gonna hang your hat
on and look back on your life and say I
did that those are the kind of goals you
want to set for yourself and when you do
that you will be more excited you will
more have more passion and you'll bring
that to your life and your business and
your family the excitement of having
great goals believe
my father told me when I was a small boy
that he strongly recommended I set my
goal so high that I couldn't achieve him
in my lifetime because he had he had set
his goals he said go after the
depression that he would be a
millionaire and have a got in a
plantation and he had a small plantation
and he had a small yacht and he was a
millionaire and he couldn't refocus his
life and he said I made a mistake doing
that I'm having a lot of trouble now
because I've achieved my goals and he
said please set your goals so high that
you can't achieve them so I'm trying to
help save the world and I think that's
probably you know higher than I I don't
anticipate achieving it completely but I
would like to see those he watching I
love to know what bulls you have leave
it in the comments below let me know
what big goals you have what you want to
accomplish in this world
write it down feel inspired inspire
others and please share it you guys like
this video thumbs up below you want to
see more like this click my face
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much I'll see you soon